[Aplausos]
[Música]
bangladesh es el mejor país del mundo si
no te gusta estar solo este país tiene
la mitad de la población de eeuu pero
concentrada en una superficie
equivalente al estado de illinois es el
país más densamente poblado del mundo
[Música]
y también se trata de una de las
economías de más rápido crecimiento en
los últimos años en solo dos décadas
bangladesh ha reducido la pobreza a la
mitad hablamos del líder mundial en
fabricación textil sólo superados por
china de hecho seguro que la camisa que
lleváis puesta ahora mismo o los
pantalones están fabricados en este país
pero esperad un momento porque todavía
no es el momento de descorchar el
champagne si bangladesh crece muy rápido
pero todavía el 13% de su población vive
con menos de dos dólares al día estos
son más de 20 millones de personas si a
esto le sumamos el hecho de que
bangladesh es un país de mayoría
musulmana tenéis el caldo de cultivo
perfecto para que ocurran cosas como
estas
la actividad terrorista en bangladesh se
incrementó en el 2016 pese a una caída a
nivel global pese a que bangladesh tiene
una constitución laica hay regiones
donde se la pida a las mujeres adúlteras
y el 80% de la población cree que habría
que cambiar la legislación para que
respete los principios de las áreas
mientras tanto pese al radicalismo de
algunos de sus ciudadanos bangladesh
tiene a una mujer como primera ministra
sheikh hasina que como veremos es la
persona más poderosa del país
[Música]
y la líder de la oposición khaled hacía
es también una mujer en resumen que el
país vive un momento especialmente tenso
especialmente si tenemos en cuenta que
el año que viene en 2018
bangladesh va a celebrar unas nuevas
elecciones así que la pregunta es puede
bangladesh convertirse en una república
islámica porque decimos que este país es
una bomba demográfica hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
dos hombres y un destino' en el año 1947
en las colonias de la india se separan
del imperio británico
[Música]
la parte donde el hinduismo era la
religión oficial se convirtió en lo que
ahora conocemos como la india y las
partes donde la población islámica era
la mayoritaria dieron lugar a otro país
que se llamaba pakistán podéis
imaginaros el caos millones de
desplazados violencia en las calles y
limpieza étnica de las minorías por
motivos religiosos un absoluto desastre
que incluso podemos ver en este mapa en
el medio la india y a la izquierda y la
derecha la república de pakistán con un
sistema político basado en el islam
2.200 kilómetros separaban las dos
partes del nuevo estado pakistaní como
podéis imaginar esto tenía todas las
papeletas para no salir bien más allá
del islám estas dos partes no tenían
nada que ver entre ellas ni siquiera
hablaban el mismo idioma los
paquistaníes del oeste despreciaban a
los del este y los del este los
bengalíes querían independizarse así es
como en 1971 estalló la llamada guerra
de la liberación
se estima que entre 300.000 y 3 millones
de ciudadanos perdieron la vida pero
como resultado nació un nuevo país la
república popular de bangladesh y así es
como este señor que veis en pantalla
mujibur rahman o más conocido como
bangabandhu se convirtió en el primer
presidente del país como os podéis
imaginar la nueva constitución de este
país era lo opuesto a la ley paquistaní
bangabandhu diseña un sistema político
completamente laico es más se apuntó a
la ideología de moda en la época el
llamado socialismo árabe que era un
cóctel ideológico que combinaba líderes
autoritarios economía centralizada y
laicismo
[Música]
pero las cosas no fueron muy bien para
el pobre bangabandhu cuatro años más
tarde de hacerse con el poder toda su
familia murió en un golpe de estado
organizado por los sectores pro
paquistaníes toda su familia bueno en
realidad sus dos hijas sobrevivieron
entre ellas sheikh hasina la que hoy es
primera ministra de bangladesh pero
volvamos al golpe de estado porque tras
dos años de inestabilidad política y de
influencia del 'tío sam' el general y ar
rahman se puso al frente de un nuevo
gobierno y una de sus decisiones más
controvertidas fue la de concederle la
amnistía a los islamistas que habían
asesinado a bangabandhu
[Música]
y es como nació la división ideológica
que ha marcado la vida política en
bangladesh por un lado tenemos a la
familia y el partido del general rahman
el partido nacional bangladeshí o pnp
por sus siglas se trata de una coalición
conservadora con una fuerte presencia de
partidos islámicos por ejemplo aquellos
sectores que participaron en el golpe de
estado de 1975 se hicieron miembros de
esta coalición por el otro lado tenemos
al partido del difunto bangabandhu la
llamada liga awami que podríamos decir
que es socialista y laica
el general rahman gobernó durante cuatro
años más después otro golpe de estado
que llevó a bangladesh a una dictadura
militar que se prolongó hasta 1991 a
partir de ahí la democracia volvió al
país pero espera de un momento porque la
democracia bangladeshí es de todo menos
democrática
dos mujeres y un destino desde 1991
estos dos partidos políticos han tenido
a dos líderes as en el bnp tenemos a
khaled hacía la viuda del general rahman
en la liga awami tenemos a sheikh hasina
que es la hija de bangabandhu desde
entonces las elecciones han sido una
disputa entre estas dos mujeres que se
alternan en el poder cada cinco años
ninguna de ellas consigue repetir el
mandato y es más las elecciones en
bangladesh son de todo menos una fiesta
de la democracia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
normalmente el partido que está en la
oposición en ese momento organiza
protestas violentas y huelgas que
paralizan el país durante días sin
embargo todo esto cambio en el año 2006
en ese momento la liga awami de hasina
estaba disconforme con el proceso
electoral hasta el momento puedes todo
como siempre pero esta vez el ejército
trató de dar un golpe de estado para
poner algo de orden en el país algo
parecido a lo que ocurrió en los años 80
las elecciones se tuvieron que posponer
por dos años
finalmente hasina se hizo con el
gobierno y aprendió una valiosa lección
lo importante no es ganar unas
elecciones sino mantener el poder
recordáis que os decía que el general
rahman concedió la amnistía a todos los
asesinos de bangabandhu en los años 70
pues bien su hija tenía muy buena
memoria
así que utilizó estos recuerdos del
pasado para meter en la cárcel a todos
esos islamistas que habían participado
en el golpe de estado del 75 y que
podían hacer la sombra política
[Música]
bangladesh ejecuta al líder del
principal partido islamista por si esto
fuera poco
asina rompió una de las mayores
tradiciones políticas en bangladesh
normalmente durante las épocas
electorales el parlamento creaba un
gobierno neutral para garantizar un
proceso electoral limpio pero hasina no
estaba dispuesto a dejar el poder así
que en el año 2014 la oposición boicoteó
las elecciones y por supuesto siendo la
única candidata a cinna arrasó en los
comicios con un 79 por ciento del voto
el partido del gobierno en bangladesh
gana las elecciones de nuevo en una
votación boicoteada en otras palabras
que a día de hoy en el año 2017 asigna
es el líder más fuerte en toda la
historia de bangladesh y esto no es
ninguna broma si tenemos en cuenta que
este país tiene más de 160 millones de
habitantes así que la pregunta es que da
a alguien en este país que pueda
enfrentarse al poder de sheikh hasina y
la respuesta es sí
bomba demográfica como decíamos al
principio en bangladesh hay más de 20
millones de personas que viven en la
pobreza extrema son jóvenes y
extremadamente religiosos en otras
palabras son el caldo de cultivo
perfecto para cualquier movimiento
islamista que se precie y si ya sé lo
que estáis pensando con seca no nos
habías dicho que a bangladesh es una de
las economías de más rápido crecimiento
del mundo pues si tenéis razón y
precisamente por eso 20 millones de
pobres son un auténtico problema
veréis si un día queréis montar vuestra
propia revolución populista evitar ir a
un país que sea extremadamente pobre el
mejor lugar para un movimiento radical
es precisamente un país que está
creciendo o que está saliendo de una
crisis esa es vuestra ventana de
oportunidad en ese momento es cuando los
ciudadanos más desfavorecidos pueden
empezar a envidiar a aquellos que están
mejorando su situación por eso esos 20
millones de pobres son un nicho de
mercado perfecto para la radicalización
y una amenaza para la estabilidad del
país y eso explica que los atentados
terroristas sean cada vez más frecuentes
en bangladesh desde el año 2013 muchas
de las víctimas son blogueros ateos que
difunden sus ideas por internet pero la
auténtica alarma no llego hasta el año
[Música]
atentado en bangladesh los pistoleros
del issys matan a 22 rehenes en un
restaurante de daca
desde entonces sheikh hasina ha
intentado frenar el terrorismo sin
embargo como decía en 2018 hay
elecciones y el gobierno quiere ganar
apoyos entre los sectores más religiosos
de la población eso explica que hasina
haya recibido con los brazos abiertos
esa inversión de más de mil millones de
dólares que venían de arabia saudita
para construir 560 mezquitas en el país
a la vez su gobierno ha frenado las
leyes que facilitaban que las mujeres
pudieran cobrar herencias o las que
prohibían los matrimonios con menores de
edad
[Música]
pero esto no es todo un grupo de
propagandistas islámicos llamados jefaza
e islam envió al gobierno una agenda con
13 sugerencias políticas por ejemplo
querían que las enseñanzas que se
imparten en las escuelas islámicas
radicales tuvieran el mismo rango que un
título académico homologado y en contra
de lo que cabría esperar che hasina está
llevando a cabo muchas de estas reformas
propuestas por los integristas
y no olvidéis que al menos en teoría el
partido de hasina la liga awami es el
partido que defiende el laicismo frente
a las ideas más tradicionalistas del bnp
[Música]
así que la pregunta es creéis que
bangladesh puede convertirse en una
república islámica de facto o
simplemente es un juego político para
que sea así no consolide su poder de
cara a las elecciones de 2018
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a visual
político para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]